ALAN ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES
BECKER BORGEAS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE DALLY DODD DURAZO EGGMAN
LASER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERZBERG HUESO HURTADO JONES
CAM WALKER LAYERED LLEVA LIMON
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MIN NEWMAN
NIELSEN OCHOA BOGH PAN
PORTANTINO ROSSI RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG WIECKOWSKI
WINNER WILK. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. WITH THE MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL
PLEASE RISE. WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
CORTESE AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ACTUALLY REMAIN STANDING IN
WOULD BE LED IN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE BY SENATOR WIENER
SENATOR CORTEZ.
INTERPRETATIVE.
A LOT OF MEDICAL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. I WILL NOT BELIEVE IN
THE LAW OF THE STRONGEST IN THE
POWER OF THE POWERFUL. I WANT TO
BELIEVE IN THE RIGHT OF ALL. IN
THE OPEN HAND IN THE STRENGTH OF
THE NONVIOLENT. I WILL NOT
BELIEVE THAT I DON'T HAVE TO
CONCERN MYSELF WITH WHAT HAPPENS
FAR FROM HERE. I WANT TO BELIEVE
THAT THE WHOLE WORLD. IS MY
HOME. AND THAT ALL REAP WHAT ALL
HAVE SOON. I WILL NOT BELIEVE
THAT I CAN COMBAT OPPRESSION OF
THEIR IF I TOLERATE INJUSTICE
HERE. I WANT TO BELIEVE THAT
WHAT IS RIGHT IS THE SAME HERE
AND THERE. AND THAT I WILL NOT
BE FREE. WELL EVEN ONE HUMAN
BEING IS EXCLUDED. I WILL NOT
BELIEVE THAT ANY EFFORT IS IN
VAIN. BUT I WILL DARE TO
BELIEVE. IN THE DREAM OF GOD. A
NEW HEAVEN AND A NEW EARTH WHERE
JUSTICE AND LOVE RAIN. GRACIOUS
GOD I WANT TO BELIEVE HELP MY
UNBELIEF. AMEN I SHOULD ADD THAT
WAS DOM HELDER KAMERA FROM THIS
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. OUR
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. HI.
OUR MEMBERS MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE TEAM READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WOULD
TEAM WORK BETWEEN READ. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DOING
BREAD AND A MINUTE. A DOCTOR
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED AND MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES SENATOR
SCANNER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I MOVED THE ADOPTION OF
AUTHORS AMENDMENTS FOR BUDGET
BILLS THAT CROSS THE DESK ON
FRIDAY SATURDAY AND SUNDAY MARCH
ELEVENTH TWELFTH AND THIRTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY TWO THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE ADOPTED
PUBLISHED AND THEN RETURNED TO
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
NELSON. MR PRESIDENT I RISE TO
OPPOSE AND ASK FOR A ROLL CALL
VOTE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR ADOPTION BY SENATOR SKINNER
SHE'S ASKING FOR A VOTE SENATOR
NELSON'S ASKING FOR NOVO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
FACE NO BACKER I PORCHES.
BRADFORD I COME BEARING CORTEZ
HE HI DALLY NO DOG HI I TORONTO
I EGGMAN I GLAZER. HI
CONSOLIDATES I GROW NO HERTZBERG
HI WEST SO. HI FURTADO. JONES NO
KIM WALKER I LAYERED HI LLEVA HI
THE MON I MEAN WIRE I MELINDA'S
NO MAN. I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A
SHOW OF VOGUE NO PAM. HI FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO. SKINNER
I STERN AMBERG HI MIKE HOW SKI I
WINNER I WILL KNOW. I SPOKE WELL
OF MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. PORCHES
CABRERA HER TADO. RUBIO STERN.
MARCH TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS EIGHT
THE MOTION CARRIES. NOW MEMBERS
ROOM I'M MOVING ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE HAVE SEEN ITS SECOND READING.
ITEM ONE MANAGER TERRY PLEASE RE
SENATE BILL EIGHT NINETY SIX
WITH AMENDMENTS. K. NOW MOVING
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
SENATOR LAYERED YOU'RE PREPARED.
FOR GEORGE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT BUT WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF APPOINTMENTS TODAY THE FIRST
ONE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF DIANE
DOBBS TO THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS MISS DOBBS IS SERVED AS
A COMMISSIONER ON THE BOARD
SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN PRIOR TO
THAT SHE WAS DEPUTY COMMISSIONER
AN ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE AT
THE BOARD SHE WAS APPROVED IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
SECOND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION IS BASED ON THIS
APPOINTMENT SENATOR JONES. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. HI YOU
DON'T SPEAK MUCH ON THE
APPOINTMENTS BUT TODAY HOWEVER I
FEEL LIKE IT'S NECESSARY. I WILL
BE VOTING NO ON FOUR OUT OF FIVE
OF THESE APPOINTMENTS FOR THE
BOARD OF PAROLE HEARING
COMMISSIONERS. THE SAD THING
ABOUT THIS THEY ALL VOTED TO
UNDERCUT THE CRIMES BUT VICTIMS
BILL OF RIGHTS. THIS ONE NOW
GREATLY LIMIT THE ABILITY OF
FAMILY MEMBERS TO WEIGH IN
AGAINST THE STATE. LEADING THE
KILLER OF THEIR LOVED ONES OUT
OF PRISON. EARLIER THAN MAYBE
SHOULD BE AVAILABLE. PROSECUTORS
AND VICTIMS RIGHTS ADVOCATES
ARE. VERY UPSET AND DISAPPOINTED
BY THIS AND ACTUALLY VERY MAD
ABOUT IT. ADDITIONALLY THE
BOARD'S RATE OF VOTING TO
RELEASE HARDCORE KILLERS AND
RAPISTS IS NOW APPROACHING 40%
MEMBERS THEY'RE RELEASING FOUR
OUT OF TEN. VIOLENT CRIMINALS
WHO COME BEFORE THEM FOR HEARING
. WITH THE RISING CRIME RATE IN
CALIFORNIA WAY OFF THE SKILLS
RIGHT NOW IN MOST OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. I'M ASKING THAT WE
WOULD NOT APPROVE THESE
APPOINTMENTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. IN NINETEEN NINE MONTHS
AGO- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON
APPOINTMENTS. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
FIVE ATKINS I FACE NO BACKER HI
FORTUS RADFORD I HAVE I EVER FOR
TESTING HI SALLY NO DOG. FIVE
TORONTO I EXAMINE. GLAZER I
CONSOLIDATE I GROW NO HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT I WAS SO HYPER TANTO.
JONES NO CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LIVE BY I THE MON HI WIRE HI
MELINDA'S NO MAN I NEWMAN. I
NIELSEN NO A TROUBLED NO PAM HI
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH I RUBIO.
SKINNER HI STERN. NUMBER RIGHT
HI WE CASKEY I WINNER I WILL NO
ONE SECTOR PLEASE CALLED OUT TO
MEMBERS. PURCHASE HAVE I EVER
EGGMAN I HER TADO. RUBIO STERN.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN MILLS EIGHT
THE POINT MINUTES CONFIRMED
SOONER LEARN FOLLOW HIM FOR
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT FINALLY
I'M FORCED TO CONFIRMATION OF
DAVID LONG TO THE BOARD OF
PAROLE HEARINGS HE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN HE SPENT MANY YEARS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION STARTING AS A
CORRECTIONAL OFFICER IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE AND MOST RECENTLY
SERVING AS WARDEN AT THE
CALIFORNIA CITY CONGRESSIONAL A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY HE WAS
APPROVED BY THE RULESCOMMITTEE
ON MARCH SECOND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NITRO. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
SIDE ON. SO SENATOR RECORD.
THANK YOU BECAUSE I TRY TO RISE
FOR A MOMENT SOME OF THE
EXTRAORDINARY LOOKING THROUGH
HIS BACKGROUND DEFY VENTURES IS
A LIFE CHANGING PROGRAM WHERE WE
GO INTO THE PRISONS. AND IT'S
LIKE CHANGING FOR THE RECIPIENTS
WHO IS BETTER EIGHT MONTH
TRAINING ENTREPRENEURIAL
EDUCATION BUT FOR THE VOLUNTEERS
IS ABSOLUTELY LIFE CHANGING IS
THE MOST INCREDIBLE THING I'VE
EVER BEEN PART OF I THINK IT'S
JUST EXTRAORDINARY THAT GIVEN
HIS CAREER A TWENTY TWO QUICKLY
NOTE THAT RISING UP THE RANKS TO
WHARTON AND THEN TO. THE END TO
KIND OF GO AND ENGAGE IN THIS
KIND OF PROGRAM I THINK IS
REALLY EXTRAORDINARY AND- I'M
HAPPY TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF HIS.
A CONFIRMATION TODAY. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE REPORT ON APPOINTMENT.
YOU NEED C. NINE MENTOR TO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON FILE
ITEM FOR. ALAN HI ARCHULETA. HI
ACTON'S. I FACE. BACKER FIVE
PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T WHAT HAS HE HI DOLLY. NO
DON. HI TORONTO HI EXAMINED EYE
LASER. I CONSOLIDATE FIVE GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO JONES NO CAMEL UNDER I
LAYERED I LABOR I THE MON. WIRE
I MELINDA'S NO MAN. I NEWMAN I
NIELSEN NO A SHOW OF BOTH. PAM I
FORTUNE TINO FIVE ROCK I REVIEW
I SKINNER. I STERN. I'M VERY
CALM HI WAKE OUT SKI I WINNER I
WILL KNOW SOME SURGERY PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. EIGHT NO
FOR JUST COME BY YELLOW. HER
TADO THE MON I TRIED BOTH. STERN. AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT MILLS
SEVEN THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW MOVING ON
FOLLOWING FIVE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM FIVE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF MACHEL MINOR TO
THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS NOW
MISS MINOR SIR FOR MANY YEARS
NOW VARIETY OF ROLES AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION SHE WAS FIRST
APPOINTED TO THE BOARD IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN HE WAS APPROVED BY THE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH SECOND
I RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR NOISE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION IN THE VERY CENTER
JONES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT IS
MINOR IS SUPPORTED BY SOME
VICTIM RIGHTS ADVOCATES AND
ORGANIZATIONS SO I WILL BE
VOTING FOR HER APPROVAL TODAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT IN NINETEEN NINE I'M
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I
BASE FIVE BECKER. I PORCHES
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON'T
CORTESE HI DOLLY NO DODD. I
TORONTO HI ADMIN I. LASER EYE
CONSOLIDATES I GROWTH. I HEARD
SPURRED BY WESTERN HI HER TADO.
JONES I CAN LONGER I LAYERED I
LABOR. FIVE THE MON I REQUIRE I
MELINDA'S. MANY I NEWMAN I
NELSON BY A SHOW OF BOTH I PAN.
I FORTUNE TINO I BROUGHT I RUBIO
I SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER I LIKE
HOW SKI I WINNER. I WILL KNOW.
OUR MANAGER TO POLICE CALLED OUT
TO MEMBERS. PORGES CABALLERO.
HER TADO MELINDA'S. STERN.
SENATOR ALAN ARE YOU WISHING TO
CHANGE YOUR VOTE- HIGHS THIRTY
THREE NOSE TO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM SIX THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF EXCEL
SURE REEF TO THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS BEFORE BEING APPOINTED
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN HE SERVED AS
A DEPUTY COMMISSIONER IN
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE AT THE
BOARD HE ALSO SERVED AS A JUDGE
PRO TEM FOR THE LOS ANGELES
SUPERIOR COURT HE WAS APPROVED
BY THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
SECOND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
APPOINTMENT. IN NINETEEN NINE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS I
FACE NO BACKER I FORGES BRADFORD. I COME BY ADAM QUARTET THREE
FIVE DAILY. NO DOG I- AWESOME HI
EXAMINED EYE LASER I CONSOLIDATE
HIGH GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG I WAS
SO HI HER TADO. JONES NO CAN'T
MOTOR I LAYERED I LIVE ON. I THE
MON I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S NO MAN
I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A CHILL OF
BOTH. NO PAM I FORTUNE TINA I
BROUGHT I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN. NUMBER HI I LIKE HOW SKI
. I WINNER I WILL KNOW. PLEASE
CALL THE OB TO MEMBERS. PORGES
HAVE I EVER HER TADO TURN. MARCH
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT THE
FOREMAN IS CONFIRMED NOW MOVING
ON FOLLOWING HIMSELF THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT FOLLOWED HIM SEVEN
IS THE CONFIRMATION OF TROY TYRO
TO THE BOARD OF PAROLE HEARINGS
HE SERVED ON THE BOARD SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN PRIOR TO THIS
APPOINTMENT HE SERVED AS
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION HE WAS APPROVED IN
THE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
SECOND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT. THE
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
APPOINTMENT HEARING AND SEEING
ON SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ACTIONS I HATE. NO BACKER. I
PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE A- FOR
TESTING I DAILY NO DOG HI DOCTOR
ALSO HI ADNAN I GLAZER ICONS ALL
AS I GROW. NO HERTZBERG I WAS SO
I HER TADO. JONES NO CAN WALKER
. I LAYERED I LIVE ON I LIVE
ALONE I REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. NO
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN NO A SHOW
ABOUT NO PAM. HI FORTUNE TINO I.
ROSS. FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN. NUMBER I WAS ASKING I
WINNER I WILL. NO SIR TERRY
PLEASE CALL THAT'S A MEMBERSHIP
. PORGES BY OTHER HER TADO STERN
. AUGUST TWENTY EIGHT MILLS
EIGHT THE POINT IS CONFIRMED NOW
MOVING TO OUR FINAL APPOINTMENT
OF THIS MORNING FOLLOW ME THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THIS IS A
NUMBER OF APPOINTMENTS AND ONE
ITEM OF FILE ITEM MADE US A
CONFIRMATION OF JOSE DAY HIS
ZEUS LOPEZ AND DR ELIZABETH
PARTY TO THE BOARD OF FORESTRY
AND FIRE PROTECTION MEGHAN ELLIS
TANYA FAIRLY AND RESEARCH IS
BUILT TO THE BOARD OF BARBERING
AND COSMETOLOGY AND CARL HAAS TO
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
COMMISSION. THESE APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH SECOND
I RESPECTFULLY ASKS FOR MY PHONE
. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE APPOINTMENTS. ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE APPOINTMENT
HERE NINETEEN NINETY MINUTES
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ROLLING
FOLLOWING MADE. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I ADKINS I HATE I BECKER. I
PORCHES BRADFORD I HAVE A I
DON'T CORTESE I DALLY I DONT. I
TORONTO I MEAN I LASER. I
CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH. I HURTS
BERG HI WEST SO HI HER TADO.
JONES I CAN'T LONGER I LAYERED I
LIVE ON. I THE MON HI WIRE I
MELINDA'S. I MEANT I NEWMAN I
NELSON I WOULD SHOW UP BOTH. HI
PAM I FORTINO I ROCK I RUBIO. I
SKINNER. HI STERN AMBERG HI HI
MIKE HOW SKI I WINNER I WELL I.
MARCH THIRTY SIX MILLS ZERO
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED NOW
MEMBERS WERE MOVING ON TO SENATE
THIRD READING WE HAVE THREE
ITEMS THERE FIRST UP IS FALL
ITEM EIGHTEEN SENATOR KERR
CORTESE ARE YOU PREPARED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY BY
SENATOR CORTEZ C. RELATIVE TO
VISUAL AND PERFORMING ARTS
EDUCATION MONTH. THIS
INTERPRETATION THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. TODAY I'M PROUD TO
INTRODUCE S. C. R. ET TO
CELEBRATE AND RECOGNIZE VISUAL
AND PERFORMING ARTS EDUCATION
MONTH ARTS EDUCATION IS LINKED
TO HIGHER TEST SCORES ACROSS ALL
SUBJECTS AS WELL AS LOWER
DROPOUT RATES. SOME FACTS
STUDENTS WITH ARTS EDUCATION ARE
FIVE TIMES LESS LIKELY TO DROP
OUT OF SCHOOL. FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO BE RECOGNIZED FOR
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT THREE TIMES
MORE LIKELY TO BE ELECTED TO
CLASS OFFICE FOUR TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO RECEIVE A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE. TWO TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE IN 30%
MORE INCLINED TO PURSUE A
PROFESSIONAL CAREER. IN BEYOND
THE CLASSROOM EDUCATION IN THE
ARTS IS DEMONSTRATED TO HELP
NURTURE COLLABORATION AND FOSTER
STUDENT WELLNESS INCLUDING
MENTAL WELL BEING. AS A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I'VE SEEN
FIRSTHAND HOW STUDYING THE ARTS
IN SCHOOL CAN HELP A STUDENT
DEVELOP THEIR WORK ETHICS STUDY
HABITS. TIME MANAGEMENT SKILLS
CREATIVITY AND PROBLEM SOLVING
ABILITIES AND THOSE OF US WHO
ARE PARENTS NOT KNOW THAT FIRST
HAND AS WELL. THE ARTS BUILDING
HELP UNIFY COMMUNITIES. I WANT
TO NOTE THAT THIS RESOLUTION
SUPPORTED BY CREATE CALIFORNIA-
THAT RCENTLY MERGED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR ARTS
EDUCATION IN OUR LEADERS IN
PROMOTING THE ARTS EDUCATION
CREATIVITY IN OUR SCHOOLS. BUT
LET US CONTINUE TO RAISE
AWARENESS AMONG STATE COUNTY AND
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS ABOUT
THE ESSENTIAL VALUE OF ARTS
EDUCATION OR SCHOOLS. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HEARING
CENA THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
KNOW AND THROW.
M. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ALWAYS CONSULT. MEMBERS
THIS ITEMS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
C. NINE. OZ THIRTY FIVE. KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES NEXT UP
IS FALL ITEM NINETEEN BY SENATOR
RUBIO. SENATOR RUBIO YOU
PREPARED. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION EIGHTY ONE BY SENATOR
RUBIO RELATIVE TO SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS SENATOR RUBIO
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT S. C. R.
EIGHTY ONE WHICH PROCLAIMS MARCH
SEVENTH TO MARCH ELEVENTH TWENTY
TWENTY TWO A SCHOOL BREAKFAST
WEEK THIS WEEK RECOGNIZES THE
IMPORTANCE OF SCHOOL NUTRITION
PROGRAMS IN THE CRITICAL ROLE OF
STAFF AND MAKING SURE OUR
CHILDREN ARE PROVIDED WITH VITAL
MEALS. THROUGHOUT THE SCHOOL
DAYS AS A PUBLIC SCHOOL TEACHER
I USED TO SEE KIDS COME TO
SCHOOL STARVING HUNGRY AND
COULDN'T PERFORM BECAUSE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A MEAL SO I USED TO
KEEP SNACKS IN MY DRAWERS AND
ALWAYS MAKE SURE THAT I HAD
SOMETHING TO OFFER. BUT THAT IS
NOT ACCEPTABLE FOR CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN WE KNOW THAT ONE IN SIX
IN THE STATE WERE LIVING WITH
FOOD INSECURITY BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND TRAGICALLY DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO REGULAR BREAKFAST
WHICH IS THE MOST IMPORTANT MEAL
OF THE DAY. AND NOW THAT
STATISTIC WILL LIKELY GO UP
AFTER THE PANDEMIC AND AS WE
COME OUT OF THE PANDEMIC WE MUST
ENSURE OUR CHILDREN EAT
BREAKFAST TO ALLOW THEM TO EXCEL
ACADEMICALLY AS WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS A CORRELATION. AND WE
NEED THEM TO IMPROVE THEIR
CONCENTRATION WHICH WILL
ULTIMATELY RESULT IN HIGHER TEST
SCORES I ALSO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND ALL THE ESSENTIAL
EMPLOYEES THESE ARE CONSIDERED
FIRST RESPONDERS. AND I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE WORK THEY DID
DURING THE CRITICAL TIMES EARLY
IN THE PANDEMIC SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ACROSS THE STATE HAD TO
IMPLEMENT AN ENTIRELY NEW SYSTEM
MANY WORKING WITH LOCAL
NONPROFITS TO CREATE PICKUP
SITES DURING THE PANDEMIC THIS
WAS IMPERATIVE FOR STUDENTS AND
FAMILIES TO RECEIVE HEALTHY
MEALS. I WANT TO ALSO THANK OUR
SPONSOR NO KIDS HUNGRY
CALIFORNIA WHO HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC THEY PROVIDED GRANTS
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING MY
DISTRICT BUT NOT ONLY PROVIDE A
BREAKFAST BUT ALSO SUPPER FOR
SOME OF OUR FAMILIES INCLUDING A
MONEY CITY SCHOOL DISTRICT AMANI
UNION HIGH I SCHOOL. AS WELL AS
ROAST MEAT. I AM PROUD OF THE
WORK WE'VE DONE HERE IN THE
STATE. WITH FREE SCHOOL MEALS
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH
BEGINS THIS ACADEMIC SCHOOL YEAR
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT NO CHILD
EVER GOES HUNGRY AGAIN. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM SENATOR NEAL NEWMAN
AND THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THAT
MEMBERS I RISE AS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION WHICH PROPERLY
ACKNOWLEDGES AND CELEBRATES. THE
NATIONAL SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAM DURING NATIONAL SCHOOL
BREAKFAST WEEK THIS ESSENTIAL
PROGRAM CONTINUES TO BE A
CONSISTENT RESOURCE FOR CREATING
HEALTHY AND LIFELONG EATING
HABITS IMPROVING FOOD SECURITY.
AND ADVANCING THE HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S
SCHOOL CHILDREN. STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SCHOOL BREAKFAST IS ESSENTIAL IN%
HELPING CHILDREN LEARN TO
PERFORM AS VALIDATED BY ENHANCE
CONCENTRATION IMPROVE TEST
SCORES AND FEWER CLASS
DISRUPTIONS. THROUGHOUT THE
WORST OF THE PANDEMIC THE
EDUCATORS AND STAFF RUN SCHOOL
NUTRITION PROGRAMS AND THEIR-
AND THEIR STAFFS WERE NOTHING
SHORT OF A ROW I CAN SAFELY AND
CONSISTENTLY CRAFTING WAYS
PROVIDE MEALS TO CHILDREN AND
THEIR FAMILIES. OFTEN AT
SUBSTANTIAL RISK TO THEIR OWN
HEALTH NOW AS THE PANDEMIC
HOPEFULLY CONTINUES TO SUBSIDE
THE SCHOOL BREAKFAST PROGRAM AND
SCHOOL NUTRITION STAFF WILL
CONTINUE TO PLAY A VITAL ROLE IN
MEETING THE NUTRITIONAL NEEDS OF
CHILDREN ACROSS CALIFORNIA. OUR
STATE'S PROSPERITY TOMORROW IS
INEXTRICABLY LINKED TO THE
PHYSICAL AND INTELLECTUAL HEALTH
OF OUR STUDENTS TODAY THE MOST
IMPORTANT MEAL OF THE DAY I
COMMEND MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BALDWIN PARK FOR BRING FOR THIS
RESOLUTION. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NOT. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HERE IN NC NINE CENTER
REVIEW WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU FROM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL IN FALL OF
NINETEEN. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. I FACE. I BACKER. HI
PORCHES BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM
CORTEZ C. I. DALI. I DON. HI
THERE ARE SO HI AIKMAN. HYPHEN
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATE HIGH GROWTH
. HI HURTS BERG. WHERE SOME. I
HER TADO JONES I CAN LONGER HI
WHERE'D I LABOR I THE MON.
REQUIRE I MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S I
MAN I NEWMAN I NIELSEN I WOULD
SHOW UP BOTH I CAN. HI FOUR
TWENTY NINE. HI RALPH I RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI STERN NUMBER I LIKE
HOW SWEET I WINNER I WILL. ALL
EYES THIRTY THREE NOS ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED NOW MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY SENATOR
RUBIO YOU'RE PREPARED AND I'M
SECTOR YOU MAY READ SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION EIGHTY
THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO RELATIVE
TO WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION WEEK
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
OF THE SENATE TODAY ARE PRICED
TO RESENT S. YOU ARE EIGHTY
THREE WHICH PERTAINS THIS WEEK
MARCH SIX TO THE TWELVE AS WOMEN
IN CONSTRUCTION WEEK. THIS MONTH
WE CELEBRATE MANY WOMEN FROM ALL
WALKS OF LIFE AND AN HONOR
NATIONAL WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH
THIS WEEK WE CELEBRATE WOMEN WHO
WORK IN CONSTRUCTION THESE WOMEN
ARE SMASHING THROUGH BARRIERS.
WITH NEEDS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND HOUSING THERE'S NEVER BEEN A
MORE IMPORTANT TIME TO BUILD A
MORE DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE
WORKFORCE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
GENDER RACE OR ETHNIC BACKGROUND
GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENTER. AN
INDUSTRY THAT HAS WELL PAYING
JOBS. THAT MEANS WORK FORCE
TRAINING FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THE
WORK FORCE IN CALIFORNIA NEED
SKILLED WORKERS AND WE MUST
CONTINUE TO ATTRACT MORE WOMEN
INTO THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY.
WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION HOLD MANY
DIFFERENT ROLES INCLUDING
PROJECT MANAGER POSITIONS
WORKING IN THE BUILDING TRADES
IN ARCHITECTURE AND MUCH MORE.
ACCORDING TO THE DATA FROM THE
DIVISION OF APPRENTICESHIP
STANDARDS JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
BUILDING TRADES APPRENTICESHIP%
PROGRAMS COLLECTIVELY GRADUATE
OVER 90% OF WOMEN APPRENTICES IN
CALIFORNIA. LET'S EDUCATE AND
INSPIRE PARENTS EDUCATORS AND
CAREER COUNSELORS TO ENCOURAGE
WOMEN'S. IN CALIFORNIA'S YOU TO
ENTER INTO A REWARDING CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES IN CONSTRUCTION AS
A FORMER TEACHER I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS. LASTLY I JUST
WANT TO TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE EVERYONE'S
CONTRIBUTION ESPECIALLY OUR
WOMEN WHO HELPED BUILD OUR NEW
HOMES AND THEN YOU'LL SWING
SPACE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. TURNING TO
NON MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE FOR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL ON THE SIDE OF.
HEARING C. NINE OZ THIRTY THREE
KNOWS IT ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED NOW MEMBERS WERE MOVING
ON TO THE COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS ARE THERE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS. SENATOR
RAW. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT THE
JOINT- BUSINESS AND PROFESSION
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEES
OF THE SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY
WILL MEET WILL CONVENE IN THE
CHAMBER AT ELEVEN AM. THE
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONALS JOINT
COMMITTEE WILL MEET. AT THE END
OF SESSION HERE ON THE FLOOR. AT
ELEVEN AM ME CHENEY I'M SORRY.
MEMBERS NOW RETURNING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS NOW IS THE TIME
FOR ADJOURN IN MEMORY WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF A JOURNEY MEMORIES
FIRST UP IS SENATOR BATES.
YOU'RE PREPARED SHE IS WHEN
YOU'RE READY SOONER BASIN FLOOR
GEORGE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO A JOURNEY THE
MEMORY OF ROBERT MEETING-
RESIDENT OF MY HOME CITY LAGOON
IN A GAL THAT TRAGICALLY DIED IN
A PLANE CRASH THIS PAST
FEBRUARY. AT THE YOUNG AGE OF
FIFTY ONE ROBERT WAS A BELOVED
MEMBER OF THE LAGOON IN A GAL
COMMUNITY AND I TRULY DEDICATED
PUBLIC SERVANT HE WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN ORANGE COUNTY. I WENT
TO SCHOOL IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EARNING HIS BA IN POLITICAL
SCIENCE FROM AZUSA PACIFIC
UNIVERSITY IN HIS LAW DEGREE
FROM PEPPERDINE UNIVERSITY WHERE
HE GRADUATED VALEDICTORIAN AND
THEN LATER JOINED THE LAW
SCHOOL'S BOARD OF ADVISORS. FROM
200-062-2000 EIGHTEEN ROBERT
SERVED ON THE LAGOON IN A GAL
CITY COUNCIL SERVING AS THE
CITY'S MAYOR IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE AND TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
HE WAS ALSO FOUNDING PRESIDENT
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES ORANGE COUNTY DIVISION.
BUT ROBERTS GENEROSITY AND
COMMITMENT TO HIS COMMUNITY
WASN'T JUST LIMITED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT HE ALSO PARTICIPATED
IN SEVERAL COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS SERVING ON THE
BOARD OF SOUTH COUNTY OUTREACH
WHICH SERVES THOSE WITH A
VARIETY OF FINANCIAL AND SOCIAL
NEEDS HE WAS CHAIRMAN OF THE
BOARD. OF STONY BROOK CHRISTIAN
SCHOOLS A PAST PRESIDENT OF THE
LOGIN AND GO LIONS CLUB
PRESIDENT OF THE LIBYAN INDIGO
ROTARY CLUB AND FOUNDING
PRESIDENT OF THE LAGOON IN A GAL
MILITARY SUPPORT FOUNDATION. HE
WAS A LIEUTENANT GAIL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE BOARD MEMBER WHERE HE
RECEIVED THE CHAMBER'S VOLUNTEER
OF THE YEAR AWARD IN TWO
THOUSAND SIX AND ALSO THE LAGOON
IN A GAL LIONS CLUB LINE OF THE
YEAR AWARD THAT SAME YEAR. IN
HIS PROFESSIONAL LIFE ROBERT WAS
A MANAGING PARTNER AT QUADRANT
LOG GROUP THE FIRM HE FOUNDED IN
TWENTY FIFTH. TWENTY FIFTEEN HE
WAS KNOWN AS SUCH A GOOD PERSON
WHO TREATED EVERYONE WITH
DIGNITY AND RESPECT EVERYONE WHO
KNEW ROBERT PERSONALLY AND
PROFESSIONALLY WERE DEVASTATED
BY THE NEWS OF HIS PASSING. BY
HE. TOUCHED THE LIVES OF SO MANY
PEOPLE NEVER HAVE CITY TO OUR
HIS TIE IN A TWO. TO THE IN
NEED. HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
SUSIE AND THEIR FOUR CHILDREN
JONATHAN KATIE WESLEY AND GRANT
MEMBERS I ASKED THAT WE ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF ROBERT DOUGLAS
MEETING AND SEND OUR CONDOLENCES
TO HIS FAMILY. AND THE COMMUNITY
OF LAGUNA GAL THANK YOU. MY HALF
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE WE EXTEND
OUR CONDOLENCES AND WE ALSO TO
BRING THE NAME PORTRAIT CAN BE
PROPERLY MORAL. ACCEPTED SENATOR
DOLLAR. THANK YOU- MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS. I RISE WITH A HEAVY
HEART. GARY WAYNE ARCH THAT
PASSED AWAY ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
THIRD. TWENTY TWENTY TWO AT THE
AGE OF SEVENTY ONE. HE LIVED A
WONDERFUL LIFE OF SERVICE TO
OTHERS AND WAS LOVED BY MANY
INCLUDING HIS WIFE CONNIE AND
HIS DAUGHTER CATHERINE AND
ANGELA. AFTER ATTENDING SCHOOL
IN ORVILLE GARY ARCHER THAT
SERVED HIS COUNTRY. FOR FIVE
YEARS IN THE U. S. AIR FORCE. HE
THEN WORKED AS A VALUED EMPLOYEE
AT THE CITY OF OROVILLE PARKS
DEPARTMENT FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS.
GARY TIRED FOR THE DEPARTMENT
WHEN HE WAS ELECTED AS THE VICE
CHAIR OF THE MOORTOWN RANCHERIA
. AND LATER ELECTED AS THE
CHAIRMAN. OF THE MOORTOWN
RETREAT FOR TWENTY YEARS UNTIL
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. GARY WAS
AN ACTIVE PARTICIPANT IN LOCAL
AND STATE FEDERAL FRONTS WORKING
HARD TO ENSURE TRIBAL SELF.
GOVERNANCE IN WITH EFFORTS TO
SUPPORT AND EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES
FOR NATIVE AMERICANS. AND INDIAN
GAMING ASSOCIATIONS. NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA'S CIRCLE INDIAN
HOUSING AUTHORITY AND THE
FEATHER RIVER TRIBAL HEALTH HE
APPEARED IN COMMERCIALS
SUPPORTING INDIAN GAMING AT THE
TIME WHEN THE ISSUE WAS ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BALLOTS.
REPRESENT IS REPRESENTING HIS
PEOPLE WITH GRACE HE WAS A
HUMBLE KIND AND GENEROUS MAN WHO
FELT STRONGLY ABOUT IMPROVING
THE OPPORTUNITIES FOR INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE. I'D LIKE TO TELL SHARE
STORY ABOUT GARY'S A PERSONAL
FRIEND OF MINE- SAID ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REGGIE JONES SAWYER AND I
SAT ON THE BOYS AND MEN OF COLOR
COMMITTEE AND WE HAD THE FIRST-
THE- CONFERENCE ACTUALLY HAVE
MORE TOWN. IN THE NORTHERN PART
OF THE STATE A COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO AND WE FOUND IT WITH GARY'S
HELP WE HAD THE NATIVE AMERICAN
VOICE COME AND SPEAK TO US WE
FOUND THAT THE HIGHEST SUICIDE
RATE IN CALIFORNIA FOR MEN
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FIVE WAS
ACTUALLY NATIVE AMERICANS. AND
GERRY- CHAMPIONED- GETTING-
PEERS FOR THOSE A YOUNG MAN AND
WAS REALLY- DEDICATED TO HIS
PEOPLE SO I JUST WANT TO SAY I
WOULD HAVE A HARD HE'S REALLY
GONNA BE MISSED BY ME AND THE
COMMUNITY I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED. IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU SENATOR ALEXANDER NELSON ON
THIS AS WELL. MR PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
IQ RISE WITH A HEAVY HEART. GARY
ARCH ALETTA WAS TRUE LEADER. A
MAN WITH A GREAT HEART. HEARD
ABOUT THIS COMMUNITY. AS PEOPLE
. HE WILL WORK FOR THE CITY OF
OROVILLE FOR MANY YEARS WAS A
GOOD STEWARD OF THAT COMMUNITY
EXERTING LEADERSHIP AS ORVILLE
BECAME A PREFERRED LOCATION
RATHER THAN A SHUN CITY. GARY
HELPED LEAD THAT TRANSCENDS
ASIAN AND CHANGE OF THAT FINE
COMMUNITY. HE ALSO THE LEADER
WITHIN HIS TRIBE SPEAKING INDIAN
ISSUES. EVERYWHERE CAMPAIGNING
FOR SOME OF THE INITIATIVES THAT
WERE IMPORTANT TO THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES. TRAVELING THE STATE
. DOING ADS ADVOCATING. GARY WAS
A TRUE LEADER. WE WILL MISS HIM
. WE WISH HIS FAMILY WELL OUR
PRAYERS ARE WITH THEM. AND I
KNOW LORD WILL BE SMILING ON HIS
GREAT HEART. THANK YOU SENATOR
HOBBY OUT TO CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE WE EXTEND OUR CONDOLENCES
AND WE ARE SET TO BRING THE NAME
FOR CHILDREN START TO LIE IT CAN
BE PROPERLY MORE LAWS NEXT UP
IS. SOONER WHEN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO ASK THAT THE SENATOR IN
MEMORY OF COLONEL GEORGE IS
CHICAGO- BORN. ON FEBRUARY
TWENTY SECOND NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
IN CHICAGO. A HE MOVED TO SAN
FRANCISCO AT A YOUNG AGE AND
ATTENDED LOWELL HIGH SCHOOL.
WHERE HE JOINED THE JUNIOR
RESERVE OFFICER TRAINING CORPS
OR JROTC. AS A KID THAT. THE
PROGRAM JUMP STARTED HIS LONG
CAREER- SERVING IN THE U. S.
MILITARY AS A MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE OFFICER. AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA ARMY NATIONAL
GUARD. DURING HIS TIME IN THE
ARMY HE WAS DEPLOYED TO IRAQ
AFGHANISTAN AND KOSOVO. WITH HIS
FINAL DUTY SERVING AT THE
PENTAGON AFTER WHICH HE RETIRED
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN. UPON HIS
RETIREMENT HE BEGAN A SECOND
CAREER BACK HOME IN SAN
FRANCISCO. INSTRUCTING STUDENTS
IN JROTC- AT ABRAHAM LINCOLN
HIGH SCHOOL. LATER ASSUMING THE
ROLE OF DIRECTOR OF ARMY
INSTRUCTION- FOR THE SAN
FRANCISCO J. ROTC BRIGADE. AS A
LEADER IN SAN FRANCISCO'S JROTC
COMMUNITY- GEORGE DID AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF WORK. DID
MUCH MORE THAN MENTOR- CADETS HE
FOUGHT CONTINUAL CONTINUALLY. TO
KEEP JROTC ALIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO HIGH SCHOOLS. AND WORK
TIRES TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE THE
EXPERIENCE. FOR CADETS. HE
WORKED WITH THE VETERAN
COMMUNITY IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
ELECTED. OFFICIALS AND COMMUNITY
LEADERS. TO BOTH ENHANCE THEIR
OTC. AND TO ENSURE ITS SURVIVAL.
I HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS INCLUDE
BEING THE RECIPIENT OF TWO
DEFENSE SUPERIOR SERVICE MEDAL
THE LEGION OF MERIT BRONZE STAR
MEDAL AS WELL AS FIVE
MERITORIOUS SERVICE MEDALS.
OTHER MILITARY HONORS INCLUDE
THE FEDERAL- ON ASIAN PACIFIC
AMERICAN COUNCIL MERITORIOUS
SERVICE AWARD WHICH HE RECEIVED
IN TWO THOUSAND SIX. COLONEL
CHICAGO PASSED AWAY OF NATURAL
CAUSES ON DECEMBER THIRTIETH OF
LAST YEAR LEAVING BEHIND A
LEGACY OF SERVICE LOYALTY AND
INTEGRITY FOR HIS JROTC CADETS
TO REMEMBER. AND TO CHERISH FOR
YEARS TO COME A REQUEST THAT WE
ARE ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORGERY CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZE. I THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I RISE TO ASK THAT
THE SENATE ADJOURNED IN MEMORY
OF NANCY BECHTLE- IT'S WITH
GREAT SADNESS- THAT- WE
REMEMBER- MRS BECHTOLD BUT ALSO
WITH GREAT JOY GIVEN HER
LEADERSHIP. IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
HER CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
COMMUNITY- SHE DIED AT THE AGE
OF EIGHTY THREE. BY NANCY
BECHTLE SPENT DECADES SERVING AS
A VOLUNTEER ON BOARDS OF RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING THE
PRESIDIO TRUST SAN FRANCISCO
OPERA THE NATIONAL PARKS
FOUNDATION THE UCSF FOUNDATION
BOARD- THE WAR MEMORIAL AND
PERFORMING ARTS CENTER- AND
OTHER. IMPORTANT ORGANIZATIONS
SHE WAS ALSO A LONG TIME MEMBER
OF THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
CHARLES SCHWAB CORPORATION- AND
SERVED ON THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO SYMPHONY
INCLUDING FOUR YEARS. AS ITS
PRESIDENT HI MRS BECHTEL WAS
ALSO THE FIRST WOMAN NAMED TO
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS R. FOR
SUGAR BOWL SKI RESORT WHERE SHE
HAD GROWN UP SKIING AND RACING-
AND THE STEEPEST AND LONGEST RUN
ON THAT MOUNTAIN. I WAS LATER
NAMED AFTER HER- BORN NANCY
HOHMANN ON DECEMBER FOURTEENTH
NINETEEN THIRTY SEVEN IN NEW
YORK CITY SHE GREW UP IN SAN
FRANCISCO- SHE WAS OFTEN
CONFUSED WITH BEING PART OF THE
BECHTEL FAMILY OF SEVERANCE O
THE SAN FRANCISCO- CONSTRUCTION
CONSTRUCTION ENGINEERING FAME-
BUT SHE WASN'T. HER GREAT
GRANDFATHER ISAIAS HELLMAN ADULT-UP THREE MAJOR BANKS INCLUDING
WELLS FARGO. HER FATHER MICK
HELLMAN WAS AN ARMY OFFICER IN
WORLD WAR TWO AND HER MOTHER.
RUTH COASTLINE WAS- A QUOTE
UNQUOTE LOST THE WOMAN AIRFORCE
SERVICE PILOT TWO HUNDRED OF
WHOM. WERE FINALLY AWARDED THE
CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL JUST
LAST YEAR MRS BECHTEL GRADUATED
FROM KATHERINE DELMAR BURKE
SCHOOL IN NINETEEN FIFTY FIVE
AND ENTERED STANFORD UNIVERSITY
DURING HER FRESHMAN YEAR SHE
BECAME THE FIRST JEWISH WOMAN TO
BE INVITED. TO COME OUT AS THE
AT THE DEBUTANTE WILLIAM BALL AT
THE POWER HOTEL. YOU LOVE
STAMFORD TO MARRY HUNDRED PARIS
AND THE TWO CHILDREN MICHAEL AND
JESSICA- SHE THEN AFTER
DIVORCING MARRIED- I'M BOOKING
BECHTEL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE
THEY WERE TOGETHER FOR OVER
FORTY FIVE YEARS IN TWENTY TEN
PRESIDENT BUSH APPOINTED HER AS
CHAIR OF THE PRESIDIO TRUST
BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND SHE WAS
LATER RE APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT
OBAMA. I'M IN HER MANY ROLES-
SHE STUDIED THE ISSUES SHE
CALLED THE SHOTS AS YOU SAW
THEM- SHE MADE DECISIONS AND
STUCK TO THEM AND SHE WAS
INCREDIBLY TOUGH- SHE HAD A
GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR. AND SHE
WILL BE INCREDIBLY MISSED IN SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
TURNING TODAY IN MEMORY OF ****
BUCKLE. THANK YOU SENATOR WHEN
ARE WE UPSET YOU BRING HER NAME
FOR SO SHE CAN BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE- WE'RE RETURNING
BACK TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT APPARENTLY MY CALENDAR
WAS WRONG ON THE START TIME FOR
THE JOINT. BUSINESS AND
PROFESSION COMMITTEE HEARING
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY WE WILL
CONVENE AT TEN FIFTEEN. IN THIS
CHAMBER TODAY THANK YOU OKAY THE
JOINT HEARING ON BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONALS WILL. CONVENE AT
TEN FIFTEEN RIGHT HERE IN SENATE
CHAMBERS. RIGHT IF THERE'S NO
OTHER BUSINESS INTERACTIONS THE
DOSES COLOR MR PRESIDENT THANK
YOU SO MUCH OUR NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR MONDAY
MARCH FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AT TWO PM THANK YOU THANK
YOU THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL ALL LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
IS RECEIVED AT THE DESKS AT
WHICH TIME AN ADJOURNMENT MOTION
WILL BE MADE. WILL RECONVENE ON
MONDAY AT TWO PM. THANK YOU.